>> WE CERTAINLY ARE EXPERIENCING
A CHALLENGING SITUATION.
WE ARE SURGING RESOURCES AND WE
HAVE A MULTIPRONGED APPROACH TO
THIS.
WE HAVE SENT A VERY CLEAR
MESSAGE EARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT IS THAT WE ARE IN THE MIDST
BE PANDEMIC BORDER IS NOT OPEN
AND PEOPLE SHOULD NOT TAKE THE
PERILOUS JOURNEY HERE.
WE ARE RETURNING PEOPLE WHO
OTHER COUNTRIES.
STEVE: YEAH, THAT'S WHAT HE
SAID.
DHS SECRETARY MAYORKAS PRESSED
ON THE THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS
CAMPED UNDER THAT BRIDGE IN DEL
RIO, TEXAS HE, THE SECRETARY,
PREPARES TO VISIT THE AREA
HIMSELF FOR A FIRSTHAND LOOK.
HE'S NOT GOING TO LIKE IT.
TEXAS ATTORNEY GENERAL KEN
PAXTON JOINS US RIGHT NOW FROM
TEXAS.
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, GOOD
MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: SO WE JUST HEARD FROM THE
SECRETARY WHO SAID WE SENT A
VERY CLEAR MESSAGE THE BORDER IS
NOT OPEN.
AND, YET, THAT'S NOT THE MESSAGE
THEY ARE GETTING, IS IT?
>> NO.
AND THAT IS NOT THE MESSAGE THEY
HAVE SENT.
FROM DAY ONE, PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAID YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME
HERE.
WE WILL NOT DEPORT YOU.
AND THAT MESSAGE WAS SENT LOUD
AND CLEAR AND HAITIANS HAVE BEEN
GIVEN SPECIAL PROTECTION.
THEY ARE NOT BEING DEPORTED.
THE ONES THAT ARE ALREADY HERE.
SO THE ADMINISTRATION HAS EVEN
TOLD THEM, YOU KNOW, THE ONES
THAT ARE HERE WE ARE NOT
DEPORTING THAT MESSAGE HAS
GOTTEN THROUGH.
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE THAT PICTURE
ON THE BORDER WITH THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO GET IN.
STEVE: THAT GOES TO SHOW YOU HOW
UNEVEN THE APPLICATION OF THE
RULES IS BECAUSE IF HE GAVE THE
HAITIANS TEMPORARY PROTECTED
STATUS.
AND NOW HE IS END ISING THEM
BACK HE SAYS YEAH, I CHANGED MY
MIND.
YOU KNOW, THAT EXPLAINS WHY THE
HAITIANS ARE SAYING HEY, STOP
SENDING THEM HERE.
WE DON'T HAVE ROOM FOR OUR OWN
PEOPLE.
>> NO, THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
THERE.
IS A REASON THAT THE HAITIANS
ARE HERE.
HE INVITED THEM BY GIVING THEM
THAT SPECIAL PROTECTION AND THAT
MESSAGE GOT SENT TO THEIR
COMMUNITY.
THAT'S WHY YOU SAW SO MANY SHOW
UP SO QUICKLY.
THAT HE WAS THE TYPE OF MESSAGE
HE HAS BEEN SENDING SINCE DAY
ONE OF HIS ADMINISTRATION.
STEVE: WE UNDERSTAND THAT
APPARENTLY THEY SENT THREE
FLIGHTS OF MIGRANTS BACK FROM
SAN ANTONIO YESTERDAY.
THERE COULD BE SIX FLIGHTS LATER
TODAY.
AS THEY TRY TO LOOK LIKE WE'RE
SENDING THEM BACK.
THEY CAN'T -- YOU KNOW, IT'S
GOING TO TAKE 100 PLANES TO SEND
THAT MANY PEOPLE BACK ULTIMATELY
AS THE PEOPLE GET OFF THERE IN
HAITI.
BUT, MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, WHEN
YOU HEAR THEM SAY, ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE CLOSED THE BORDER BORDER
THAT JUST AMOUNTED TO SOME OF
YOUR GUYS AT THAT DAM, PEOPLE
WERE WALKING ACROSS AND SOME
ALSO APPARENTLY A COUPLE OF
MEXICAN POLICE ON THE OTHER SIDE
SAYING IT'S CLOSED HERE.
BUT THEY ARE COMING IN ACROSS
THE RIVER ABOUT A MILE DOWN.
YEAH, THAT'S A JOKE.
THOSE PEOPLE KNOW HOW TO GET
THROUGH.
THEY HAVE MADE NO REAL EFFORT TO
STOP THEM.
IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THE
IMMIGRATION NUMBERS IN GENERAL
WE ARE OVER 200,000 LAST MONTH.
OVER 200,000 THE MONTH BEFORE
THAT.
300 MILLION INCREASE THIS IDEA
THAT SOMEHOW THEY ARE BLOCKING
THE HAITIANS.
THEY ARE NOT BLOCKING THE
HAITIANS NO MORE THAN BLOCKING
EVERYONE ELSE.
THEY WANT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THEY WANT WHAT THAT BRINGS.
AND IT'S CLEAR FROM WHAT THEIR
ACTIONS ARE THAT THAT'S TRUE.
STEVE: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
SENATE PARLIAMENTARIAN HANDING
THE SENATE DEMOCRATS AND THE
WHITE HOUSE A BIG LOSS YESTERDAY
IN SAYING THAT THE DEMOCRATS
CANNOT JAM SOME SORT OF
IMMIGRATION REFORM OR PATHWAY
FOR CITIZENSHIP HERE IN GIGANTIC
3.5 INFRASTRUCTURE BILL THAT'S
NOT REALLY INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
AT LEAST IS THERE IS SOMETHING
RIGHT GOING ON IN WASHINGTON
TYPICALLY YOU HAVE TO
GERMANENESS.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO STICK
IMMIGRATION ON STIMULUS BILL OR
WHATEVER IT IS IT HAS TO BE
GERMANE.
I'M GLAD THE PAR PEN TARREN
RULED CORRECTLY.
STEVE: YOU HAVE BEEN WATCHING
WHAT'S GOING ON ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER FOR YEARS.
ON A SCALE OF 1 TO 10.
HOW BAD IS IT NOW?
>> I WOULD HAVE TO SAY I HAVE
NEVER SEEN IT THIS BAD.
I MEAN, WE HAVE BEEN COMPLAINING
ABOUT IT FOR DECADES.
IGNORED IT OTHER THAN THE FOUR
YEARS THAT DONALD TRUMP IS IN
OFFICE.
AND WHAT'S REMARKABLE HE HAD SO
MANY GOOD POLICIES WHETHER IT
WAS STAY IN MEXICO PROGRAM.
WHETHER IT WAS THE STOPPING THE
CATCH AND RELEASE BUILDING THE
WALL.
RESOURCES THAT WENT INTO.
NOW WE HAVE TAKEN ALL THE
OPPOSITE POLICIES AND GETTING
THE OPPOSITE RESULTS.
MY GUESS IS THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WANTS.
STEVE: WELL, THE SECRETARY IS
COMING YOUR WAY TO EYEBALL IT
HIMSELF.
KEN PAXTON, THE A.G. F